[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
inside the minds of the doomsday duo her
idea was it was for her to get rid of
the zombies the idea was for her thought
she had the power to cast out you know
she's saying the name of whatever and
with her power shocking new police
interviews try to untangle the twisted
web of chad and laurie valodebel plus
and after a few short hours
dylan was gone
murdered at the hands of this man mark
redwine's fate is sealed the hefty
sentence dealt out to the colorado man
who killed his 13 year old son and later
mark gucci's father takes the stand well
he wasn't of a converted heart and
at that point i don't think he felt the
need for it why he says his son turned
away from the mennonite faith his
parents share law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin a look inside the mind of the
so-called doomsday duo chad and lori
valodebel newly released police
interviews show detailed accounts from
friends and family leading up to the
murders of many who were close to the
day bell couple long crime dailies
sierra gillespie brings us the shocking
accounts recorded just this year
brian together the doomsday duo weaved
an intricate web of stories complete
with multiple mysterious deaths missing
persons and strong religious convictions
phrases like evil spirits zombies and
death visions hardly scratch the surface
of newly released police video
so remember that they were saying that
um tammy
had
become a
zombie
it's a murder defense you don't often
hear lori valo day bell's former
sister-in-law claiming she and husband
chad de bell believed his first wife
tammy was a zombie
they were saying that
tammy was supposed to
[Music]
die on
her trip to um
utah
she was supposed to have a she was like
he had seen it
in a vision that she was going to die in
a car accident
in the in the way there or something was
going to happen that she was going to
pass away
and then when she didn't she didn't pass
away
then what then they were saying was that
she actually did pass away but what
happened was that she was taken over by
an evil spirit
and then they were
that she had become a zombie zulema
pastenes who was married to daebel's
brother alex cox says that wasn't the
first time she heard the theory
they said the same thing about
charles
right
and then charles ended up
being shot
right
i'm thinking okay
you guys are not trying to say that you
guys are going to do something
physically to people who are
you know who are turning
into zombies lori dabel's former best
friend melanie gibb says she heard a
similar story she kept saying oh he's
getting broken down he's getting broken
down he's getting weaker he's getting
weaker we're just cast we're doing
things to help you know get him weaker
get his you know spirit out of his body
kind of a thing in july 2019 daebel's
then husband charles valo was shot and
killed by her brother alex cox who
claimed self-defense
laurie's daughter tyler ryan was
interviewed by police that same day
claiming to defend her mother from
charles valo yeah he was walking
towards my mom and i just didn't want
him
to do anything so i kind of just stuck
out the bat
i just stuck it out to be like keep your
distance just two months later tyler and
her brother jj would go missing followed
the next month by the mysterious death
of chad daybel's then-wife tammy
in april gibb told investigators lori
would cast out evil spirits and claimed
she and chad dabel knew when someone was
affected
she's starting to question if he's
seeing somebody else
laurie was
tammy that's what she would tell so
that's how they knew the evil spirits
were in her
just two weeks after tammy debell's
death chad and lori daybel got married
in hawaii in december 2019 lori's
brother alex cox dies of what is ruled a
pulmonary blood clot in june 2020 the
bodies of tylee and jj are discovered
buried on chad dabell's property both
now face multiple charges including
first degree murder and conspiracy to
commit murder
now as we've reported on law and crime
daily chad day bell's legal team is
working to move his trial out of fremont
county idaho arguing a fair and
impartial jury cannot be found there
meanwhile lori valo dabel's case is put
on hold as she is declared mentally
unfit to stand trial for law on crime
daily i'm sierra gillespie
thank you sierra on top of these newly
released interviews there is still some
speculation as to how chad dabel's first
wife tammy died in october 2019 she
mysteriously died in her sleep an
autopsy was never performed until after
she was embalmed and buried while east
idaho news reports the cause of death is
asphyxiation death investigator joseph
scott morgan tells law and crime daily
about his thoughts on the autopsy
the big problem here
is that if she's been embalmed
i don't know that there's any way to
perform
uh effective toxicology here because
remember
all of the blood
is taken out of the body and embalming
the body is infused
with
um
with embalming fluid it's it's a
replacement and that goes to
preservation so people say well why
can't they just toxicology and look for
any of these agents i understand i
understand why folks would want that but
the problem is is that all that stuff's
gone internet it's gone so
right now if in fact this is true one of
the things i'm leaning toward at least
right now unless they have other
investigative information
is the idea that they've seen something
some physical manifestation
joining us today is texas district judge
brandon birmingham and terry austin
judge we're hearing a lot more about
these doomsday beliefs do you think
these texts further the prosecution's
theory as to why the day bells allegedly
killed j.j and tyler or are they
something else
i think that this you're seeing the
background or the development of what's
going to probably turn into an insanity
plea
um these um sort of odd manifestations
of their imagination about zombies and
ridding the world of evil and all of
that has been used before
to set up an insanity defense
whether or not it's going to carry the
day depends a great deal on the actions
actually during the crime and whether or
not and this is going to be really
important whether or not actions were
taken up that prove that they knew the
difference between right and wrong
because one thing to say you believe in
zombies and all that but if you believe
in zombies and you're trying to rid the
world of evil then you would be proud of
it you wouldn't want to cover it up and
if you are i bet you the prosecution's
going to say you know the difference
between right and wrong
absolutely now terry how was this new
information involving alex cox and tammy
dabo giving greater light to the
doomsday saga that we've been following
for so long
it's becoming clearer and clearer if
it's not already clear to everyone who's
been watching this case that these
deaths are not coincidences the fact
that we have charles who was shot and
killed in july 2019 then in september jj
and tyler disappear their remains are
found that next june of course then in
october tammy dabell mysteriously died
looks like from her autopsy it was
asphyxiation and then in december alex
mysteriously dies
these deaths are not coincidences and
the fact that lori and chad are talking
about people turning into zombies that
also leads to the conspiracy theory so
there's a lot of information coming out
about these deaths yeah and with
conspiracy theories and the concept of
lack of mistake
maybe i don't know we see a lot of these
other allegations and a lot of these
facts from about tammy about alex cox
about other situations
get pulled into the jj entirely case
this could be an astounding case or
crazy case uh maybe i don't know maybe
as big as uh the robert durst case with
all the different facets but of course
we'll continue to watch and see how this
develops and give you the updates as the
doomsday duo couple cases continue thank
you both still ahead on law and crime
daily a father called to the stand as
his son is on trial for murder we bring
you the latest developments in the trial
of arizona versus mark cooch but first a
disturbing case reaches its conclusion a
colorado judge hands down the sentence
for the convicted child killer mark
redwine all that and more after this
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a sentence more than a
decade in the making is finally served
as child murderer mark redwine is given
nearly 50 years behind bars
in july a colorado jury found red wine
guilty of the murder of his 13 year old
son dylan the jury deliberated for only
six hours in november 2012 dylan was on
a court-mandated trip to see his father
over the thanksgiving holiday he
vanished that weekend and his remains
were discovered seven months later
prosecutors claimed that red wine and
killed his son after dylan confronted
him about disturbing photos of his
father dressed in women's lingerie and
eating feces out of a diaper the defense
tried to instill doubt that a wild
animal could have killed a teenager but
that argument fell short for the jury
red wine appeared in court on friday
when the judge sentenced him to 48 years
in prison with five years of parole
served concurrently before the sentence
was handed down the district attorney
gave a powerful speech
the harm that mark redwan inflicted on
his own child his own family and this
community can never be understated
he stole this bright beautiful beautiful
boy's life from him and from us all
but your honor that's only the beginning
of the terrible acts that mark redwine
perpetrated
and in the aftermath of dylan's brutal
murder we see what mark redwine is truly
made of
the person that he truly is
mark redwine killed dylan in an
unspeakable act of violence
knowingly murdered him
dylan's skull bore a fracture so
powerful and severe
it would have killed him
let's bring brac judge birmingham and
co-host terry austin to break down the
sentencing of mark redwine terry did you
see any mitigating factors that could
have reduced mark redwine's sentence by
even just a couple years
i didn't see many and neither did the
judge he only spent a few seconds
talking about those mitigating factors
he said of course there was no criminal
history he said that even the defendant
lost his own son despite the fact that
he was convicted of killing his own son
and he said that his behavior behind
bars was good but i've got to say he
went through those
aggravating factors and ultimately gave
him the maximum sentence and he even
said to the attorney sit down even if
you have an objection
i don't want to hear it put it in
writing well done judge
all right judge birmingham the thing i
love about this show i get to actually
ask a judge this question he got the max
48 years looking at the case thus far
what facts do you think led this judge
to that decision
the
brutal and violent nature the fact that
this is an innocent victim the fact that
it's a
child
all weigh heavily in and plus the
subsequent acts of the defendant who as
according to the news articles and the
video that i saw the judge said i have
seen
no remorse in you and true contrition is
a mitigating factor and if it's not
there when the proof is absolutely
overwhelming that you committed the
crime that's a big strike against you as
well absolutely i think uh the judge got
it right here if there was a time to
give the max for sentencing i think the
facts here uh lended themselves to that
so it made sense and all all around
thank you both
moving on to law and crime's weekly
podcast cop tales and cocktails on this
week's episode sergeant sean
sticks-larkin sits down with retired
nypd officer vic ferrari who tells the
host he knew he wanted to be an officer
from the time he was just five years old
i grew up in the early 70s mid 80s and
i begged my parents as a little boy to
take me to see the french connection
seven ups dirty harry and i was in the
rockford files and all that other stuff
and i knew i wanted to be an nyb
detective as a little boy and uh my
parents were like yeah yeah that's great
but after a while they started seeing
like that was the only thing i wanted to
do i took the police exam at like 19
i got hired at 21
and i went to the new york city police
academy and uh it was a great 20-year
ride i got no regrets it was the most
fun i ever had in my life
you can listen to cocktails and
cocktails on apple podcasts or wherever
you find your podcasts coming up on law
and crime daily the father of accused
mennonite murder takes the stand to
testify about his son what he had to say
in his son's defense plus a second
murder trial is underway for markeith
loyd will he face another guilty
conviction all that and more next
[Music]
welcome back the manhunt for missing
fugitive brian laundry moves forward as
police in florida deny reports that a
campsite belonging to laundry has been
recovered northport police confirmed to
law and crime daily there was no
campsite found that belonged to brian
laundry searches for the 23 year old
have been ongoing for weeks mainly in
the florida reserve where he told his
parents he was going hiking laundry's
parents confirmed this week that the
family
left his family home on september 13th
without a phone or wallet priebus
reports stated laundry left the home on
tuesday september 14th laundry is wanted
in connection with the death of gabby
petito for the unlawful use of a debit
card after potito's death
on to other top legal news an emotional
juror is excluded by the judge in the
federal trial against elizabeth holmes
this as a former grocery store chain ceo
testifies theranos didn't hold up its
end of the bargain in a 300 million
dollar partnership
in a rare move this week judge edward
davila excuses a buddhist juror who says
her religion hinders her from deciding
the fate of the former theranos ceo
juror number four told the judge she
felt guilty if her decision could put
homes behind bars for a quote long long
time
after that former safeway ceo steve byrd
took the stand saying theranose's blood
testing machine raise red flags and what
would be a failed partnership between
the two companies
bird testified that theranos staff often
missed deadlines and gave little
information about progress as safeway
poured more than 300 million dollars
into clinics in hundreds of grocery
stores across the country holmes faces
12 counts of fraud after claiming her
now defunct company theranos would
revolutionize blood testing tess later
revealed the devices had many issues and
produced varying results
and in florida markeith loyd's murder
trial is just beginning four years after
the crime was committed
markeith loyd is charged with the murder
of lieutenant debra clayton this will be
lloyd's second time potentially facing
the death penalty after a previous
conviction for the 2016 murder of his
ex-girlfriend the jury recommended life
in prison without parole for that
conviction prosecutors say that lloyd
gunned down clayton after she attempted
to arrest him for dixon's murder police
spent nine days searching for him before
finding him in an abandoned house
after more than a year's delay due to
the pandemic trial began on friday with
jury selection lloyd's defense team
plans to argue that he was acting in
self-defense the night of the shooting
claiming that clayton fired first the
defense also says that they plan to
claim insanity
when we come back both sides rest in a
mennonite murder trial what the
defendant's father had to say when he
took the stand before the defense
concluded their case
[Music]
welcome back closing arguments wrap up
and the jury is out to deliberate the
verdict in the mennonite murder trial
out of arizona
mark gooch is charged with the 2020
murder of mennonite sunday school
teacher sasha krauss after she was found
dead in a forest outside flagstaff
arizona krauss was last seen a month
before in her village near farmington
new mexico at the time gooch was
stationed at an air force base in
phoenix but cell phone records show he
drove to kraus's village the day she
went missing and his cell phone pinged
near the area where her body was later
found kraus's cause of death was
determined to be blunt force trauma and
a gunshot wound to the head the
prosecution argues gooch has a disdain
for the mennonite community after being
raised in the faith the defense argues
gooch approached the mennonite village
to reconnect with his faith the last
witness call to testify was gooch's
father who practices the mennonite faith
in wisconsin he told jurors he did not
agree with gooch's choice to join the
military and later told the prosecution
why he believed his son didn't practice
mennonite faith
when the military
in there and we had just
we highly discouraged him joining the
military
he decided to do that and then i
i'd have to look at the records probably
2018 2019.
um and the
the effort to persuade him not to join
the military was religious based
yes once in the in the air force
did you embrace mark's decision
i never
it's like this everyone has to make
their own way in life
um he'd made the decision he had to
fulfill his obligation
at that point we no longer discussed it
in in that regard because he was there
he couldn't he couldn't he'd already
signed the papers he had he had to be
there for the four years the defendant
mark he doesn't have a converted heart
what is a converted heart
what the scripture says is you've turned
from darkness to light
what it says is you've decided to con to
follow the lord with your entire heart
and what the tenets of the scripture
would call for
okay
so he had not yet turned from darkness
to life right
all right judge with the case all but
done do you think the prosecution did
enough to eliminate any reasonable doubt
this case is a great a lesson in what i
call reciprocal convergence or when you
take different facts and you see how
they tie together you have the 22
caliber rifle you've got the cell phone
you've got the text messages uh the cell
phone towers and then you have this
anti-mennonite motive that he expressed
and all of that fits if you consider one
of those compartmentalized well maybe
they're not persuasive but combined
together uh the prosecution did a very
good job of pointing out how combined
together and make a very strong case
absolutely now terry what did gucci's
father provide in terms of reasonable
doubt or do you think the defense is
already thinking about lessening a
potential sentence with this testimony
i actually think the father did not help
the defense at all he was very stoic he
showed very little emotion it was clear
that he was very strict in raising his
seven children one of the things he said
was the television is a bunch of filth
and they don't want to bring that in so
i think that at the end of the day when
he mentioned that mark didn't have a
converted heart and that he had not gone
from the darkness to the light that
actually hurt the defense and the
prosecution used that as a theme in its
summation so i think they should have
left the father off the stand altogether
absolutely probably a misstep by the
defense there but thank you judge and
thank you terry and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you